bonsoir pierre laurent merci d'être avec
nous si on comprend bien il y aura un
vaccin
du côté des pays occidentaux ou
plusieurs et d'autres absents on va dire
allez peut-être des techniques
d'ailleurs différente du côté des brics
oui effectivement les vaccins russes ne
sont pas les vaccins de la toute
dernière génération qui sont en train
d'être mises au point en occident mais
il repose sur des techniques un peu plus
ancienne et donc qu'ils sont
certainement plus fiable du point de vue
de l'utilisation directe par les
populations
il n'ya pas vraisemblablement d'effets
délétères qui peuvent se produire à long
terme les effets secondaires
on les connaît ils sont relativement
minimes et donc ce que les russes
veulent faire avec leurs vaccins
spoutnik v et deux autres qui sont en
cours de préparation
c'est de lancer une production massive
en collaborant avec leurs partenaires
des brics
alors effectivement un appel aux brics
soit 40% de la population mondiale à
s'unir pour produire des vaccins en
masse selon vous est-ce que ça a peut
aboutir
de toute manière ça va aboutir dans la
mesure où actuellement la seule chose
qui peut rassurer les populations
mondiales c'est un vaccin
quelle que soit l'importance de la
pandémie quelle que soit l'évolution des
épidémies dans différents pays au cours
des prochains mois il apparaît
aujourd'hui clairement que personne ne
sera totalement rassuré avant qu'il y
ait une diffusion importante massive des
vaccins l avantage également des des
vaccins russe c'est que ce ne sont pas
des vaccins qui dépendent d'eux
grands groupes cotés en bourse c'est à
dire que les effet d'annonce boursiers
n'existe pas donc il y a un travail qui
se fait naturellement
s'il y a des effets d'annoncé il ya eu
un effet d'annoncé
cet été avec l'annnonce du smoothie gré
c'est plutôt du point de vue politique
que cela se situe mais il n'y a pas de
conflit d'intérêts financiers entre ceux
qui fabriquent ce qui met au point le
vaccin et ceux qui le diffuse et
pourtant pierre laurin on peut le dire
voilà sans se tromper que cette annonce
cet été a été accueillie avec un certain
scepticisme voire trinca demandant les
pays parmi les pays occidentaux idem
d'ailleurs pour donald trump 1 qui avait
promis un vaccin avant novembre
finalement deux jours après sa défaite
non officiel pour l'instant aux
élections fader et biotech annonce est
effectivement l'efficacité d'un autre
vaccin suivi de près par par moderna
comment vous expliquez ça c'est deux
poids deux mesures finalement je ne
chante pas là pour le coup autant il y a
beaucoup de deux poids deux mesures dans
tout ce que l'on entend dans les
déclarations occidentales
autant là ce n'est pas réellement cela
autant c'est là c'est une méfiance à
l'égard de ceux qui peuvent venir de
russie ce qui est complètement absurde
parce que autant vous affirme que la
science russe est formidable pour mettre
au point des virus pathogènes des agents
neurotoxiques toxiques
excepté rats et là on dit ah mais ils
ont une avance considérable sur les
autres pays
mais en ce qui concerne les vaccins ce
qu'est exactement les mêmes procédures
médical et technique alors là on vous
dit un homme et ils sont pas à la
hauteur en tout cas ce que l'on voit
aujourd'hui c'est que healy a d'un côté
un vaccin qui semble commencer à
fonctionner à être produit qu'est ce que
cela va donner à l'avenir il faut rester
prudent et le l'autre côté nous avons
beaucoup d'effets d'annoncé d'une
surenchère c'est efficace à 90 à 92 à 94
8% et à chaque fois c'est au bout de
quelques jours ou de quelques semaines
remis en cause parce que eh bien il ya
un problème il ya quelqu'un qui est mort
peut-être pas de cela mais on ne sait
pas donc il faut arrêter il faut
ralentir et c'est de l'autre côté les
les rues sont très ouverts sur ce qui
concerne la mise au point de leurs
vaccins il donne accès à tout ce qu'il
faut il n'y a pas de zones d'ombré elle
est là on joue on voit que
progressivement
ç'a marché et ça fonctionne et bien
entendu il faut rester prudent on ne
sait pas quelles seront réellement les
délais de diffusion de ce vaccin où il
sera produit
est-ce que son efficacité sera aussi
forte que les autorités le prétendent
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup d'inconnu
mais en tout cas ce que l'on voit c'est
que d'un côté on essaye de progresser
d'une manière à peu près logique et de
l'autre côté on apprend des grandes
avancées qui se traduise immédiatement
par une montée des actions suivie d'une
vente par les dirigeants de ces
entreprises qui en gueulant engrangent
des bénéfices et un terme est bien au
chaud on apprend que c'est pas
exactement où si on est aussi clair
qu'on l'annoncé quelques jours au bain
merci beaucoup pierre laurin d'avoir été
avec nous en direct sur rtl france